Tên nạn sẽ ra ngày 20 thường bây, tại buồn nữ gần thành phố Tindah, Tình, Amu, đã
phí sinh mạng của toàn bộ muốn bị sống người trên mấy bây an ửa 20 thường,
bao gồm hình khác và phía hành đoàn. Theo bộ tình trạm khẩm cấp ngà,
mấy bây đã không thể hạc cãi trong lần đầu tiên, zó điều kiện thử kết nhất,
đường băng trường trượt và tâm dình hạn chế, một phải bây bòng trở lại.
Tuy nhiên chỉ có sao, phía cơ biến mất hỏi màn hình ra đã và mất liên lập hành toàn.
Lực lượng của hộ đã sắc định được bị chi mấy bây bại dơi trên xình nguy,
nơi để hình hiểm trở, khiến công tác tiếp cận gặp nhiều khó khăn.
Các mạnh vữa được tìm thấy cho thấy, mấy bây bữa nát và có giấu hiệu chế lớn tại khoảng hình khác.
Dưới trước nha đang khẩn trường điều trạm quyền nhân vụ tên nạn,
quay hai ứng chính là sai sốt trong thật hạc cãi cũng của phía công,
và khả năng thiết bị kiết thật bị hồng trong điều kiện thử tiếp sấu.
Pụ biệt một lần nữa xong lên hồi chương càng báo về an thoàn hàng không trong khu vực mền nguy có thử tiếp tục tạm.